what kind of advice would you give to a
dude when he catch his girl
um you know
cheating on them I mean a lot of times
yo dudes they will take out the angle on
the guys that the chick is cheating with
and um I think that's wrong man I think
you should charge it to the game and
move on to the next now what kind of
advice would you give to that um that
dude that's
making that sucker move coming you know
I mean trying to violate the dude that's
smashing his check yeah so there's yeah
you got to forget about the guy that's
banging your check whatever like there's
there's two different things you gotta
understand here like when when a guy
steps out on the relationship he's
cheating you know he's a he's he's
basically exercising options right like
he can go out he can go bang a chair
come home because his wife love his kids
pay all the bills you know take care of
everything do the extra quick letters go
to family events like guys don't
generally form emotional connections to
women that they're cheating on women on
the other hand they don't cheat they
betray okay betrayal is different from
cheating men cheat women women will
betray because they're betraying the
love that they committed to their guy
and they're allocating that to another
guy right women can't go around banging
you know six guys in a couple of days I
mean some do because you know they're
made for the streets sort of thing as
they like to say but at the end of the
day it's very very difficult for women
to have have unconnected sex with men so
when they step out on a relationship
it's a betrayal which is a totally
different thing and if a woman betrays
your trust why would you keep her around
like what kind of a loser are you that
you would actually you know stoop to the
level you're like well let me just keep
her because you know she touched my pee
pee one time when we have sex like once
a month right most guys are like that
they're just like okay I'm sorry baby
it's all my fault I didn't give you
enough attention it's like these guys
are Geeks they don't want to see the
reality of the world they just want to
see the rainbows and the butterflies and
consume the lies and they're the ones
that take ownership usually for her
stepping out of the relationship and
they'll go and blame themselves maybe I
didn't take her out enough maybe I
didn't tell her that I loved her enough
whatever you know it happens to be the
truth of the matter is there's probably
stuff that you did that didn't keep her
in the relationship and a lot of that
might have to be with you maybe getting
lazy you getting fat sitting around you
can't hold down a job you know you're
not competent you can't make money uh
you know if any of these things exist
and you also outside of that may select
the check that's a hoe right like I said
earlier I mean if you want to invite a
woman to your life that's been with 100
guys and think that she's going to be
exclusive to you but you're a muppet
like you're an idiot you know if you
actually believe that so see the world
for what it actually is you know there's
probably a part of the equation where
maybe you stop chasing Excellence you
know in your own life because women want
to be with the giant they want to wake
up every morning they want to look at a
guy and be like this is best that I can
do this guy's a [__] I can't wait to
come home and see him tonight be naked
when I get home she's texting them you
know throughout the day like she's got
genuine burning desire for him right so
you know there's a component that guys
have to take ownership for but at the
same time I mean if she steps out she
steps out like you take her back I'm
sorry man but you're a [__] like you're
a loser
statement um you know females betray I
think it's dope because when they do
step out it's it's definitely calculated
and precise like very calculated yeah
yeah man so I totally agree I agree with
you on that definitely
um my next question is
for you is that um do you think that
women that have achieved like
you know a great conversation that moves
them to a high level socioeconomic
status
um does that hinder them from
accomplishing bagging a good mate you
know yeah it's harder for them because
you know these like boss girls right so
there's this new phenomenon you know
today where you got these boss girls
these bad [__] you know whatever they
call themselves but it's like these
women that are like
trying like trying to be like
professional men and they think in their
heads as they're as they're doing this
or going through degrees they're taking
school they're climbing a corporate
ladder they're working extra hours
overnight uh you know putting in the
weekends and stuff like that like they
think to themselves okay now I'm going
to be attractive to a high value guy
right there's mid-30s you know by this
point the problem is is most guys that
they're that they're trying to get with
most of the guys that they feel
attractioned to they might want to start
a family with or you know settle down
with sort of thing they're not looking
for some boss girl that they're going to
come home and have disagreeable nights
with right like you're a guy you're
chasing Excellence all day you're doing
something with your life you're putting
a dent in the universe and you come home
and you've got some [__] telling you
that the curtains are wrong and you got
to go and return them and you know you
have to do this that and the other thing
and she's trying to run your life as
soon as you walk in the door high value
men don't want that they don't want to
come home to some disagreeable woman
they want to come home to a a house that
has been made made into a home you know
by their woman and their kids are looked
after there's uh there's a healthy meal
on a table the house is clean lean you
know that's what they want to come home
to they don't want to come home to some
boss girl that's also out there chasing
Excellence too now those are for the
unplugged Alphas right there's not a lot
of guys like that but there's a lot of
guys out there that are you know
professionals doctor lawyer surgeon
accountant and they also you know made
up with a woman that's also a
professional doctor lawyer surgeon
accountant or something like that
because she wants to find her equal
but the amount of guys that are at that
level that are hurt equal very very slim
there's a calculator online I think it's
called the female delusion calculator or
something like that you've probably seen
it right so I mean if you go and you
type you know um I'm looking for a guy
that's 35
uh not overweight and makes over 200 000
a year
um something like less than you know
like one percent of the male population
but women have it in their heads there's
all these guys out there that are like
hiding from them that are over six foot
tall that make loads loads of money that
don't have any baggage that uh you know
are interesting and competent and
captivating and have good families and
have a house and two cars and a boat and
all this kind of [__] they think there's
loads of these guys out there but they
don't understand that the number of guys
that that meet that very high criteria
is so low that they're all competing for
the same guy alone yes which is why
these women basically end up you know
with like these these uh Chads out there
that are banging all of these women you
know simultaneously so right these guys
are spoiled for choice and they're
trying to lock down the one guy but he's
like why when I've got like all these
options
eagerly to engage with them
the big mistake that women make is all
of those things that I described about
those qualities that they go and pursue
in their lives and their lives are
basically describing the guy that they
want to be with and they think that if
they turn themselves in the guy that
they want to be with you know that the
guy that they want to be with is going
to see them as an equal and want to be
with them right but women are Beauty
objects men are success objects so you
start telling women you know stories
like that like men select women on a
long term basis based on beauty Purity
you know things like that that's what we
look for we're not looking for your
[__] degree I don't care you don't
share your pot of gold with me
that seat women that make that kind of
um that meet that tax bracket and um yo
what are your thoughts on that because
you know there's a lot of dudes out
there that's you know promoting that and
that they should engage with a female
that makes that kind of money like I
call them suckers but I I want your
perspective on it yeah so like you're
talking about guys dating up like dating
women that make more money than them
yeah yeah
so look I mean if you're gonna get
married
I mean this sounds controversial when I
say it but if you're going to get
married the safest way to do it so you
don't get [__] if there's going to be
a divorce is to marry a woman that makes
more money than you because it's the
person that makes more money that
usually ends up paying the other person
in the in that divorce so you want to be
strategic about it as a guy you make a
hundred thousand dollars a year you can
find a chick that makes two hundred
thousand dollars a year if it doesn't
work out you're probably pretty well
protected because family law you know
will protect you the problem with it
though is that women don't like to marry
down
right they they don't yeah they want to
marry across the social economic scale
the problem is if you ask a woman you
know what their equal looks like and
then you say okay well how much money
does it need to make and it should be
something like oh he needs to make at
least 100 000 a year and then you ask
her how much money do you make she'll
say oh well I make seventy five thousand
dollars and it's like okay well how are
you in equal then right so in their mind
when they say equal they're they're
thinking higher than that so women don't
generally tend to marry down on the
social economic scale they tend to marry
up so that's that's where the problem
lies I mean you got all these boss women
out there that are running their
businesses they've climbed the corporate
ladder they've put off having kids They
smash their way through a whole bunch of
guys you know in their Partiers in the
yeah sort of thing they got a huge Notch
count they've got three cats in their
house and a fluffy white dog and all
this [__] and they think that that
is a big catch for them for like guys to
want them but they don't understand the
reality of the world it's like look
you've basically designed your life to
essentially be a man and no guy wants to
be with another dude they don't want to
be with another like a woman that
behaves like a guy that's all like that
they they want somebody
that's beautiful they want somebody
that's agreeable they want somebody
that's a compliment to their life that's
gonna add you know to life not take away
you know it's been said for for years
now and I know this is a funny statement
but it's very simple equation for women
[Music]
they have a hard time getting it back
because it's like yo like every female
thinks that yo like
that's successful and that's in that
high tax bracket Lane like they think
that
like them having this kind of
accomplishment
um turns on the dude where it does the
complete opposite to my thoughts on that
it's like yo a female that's that
um successful on that level she has to
adopt a masculine trait in order to
accomplish those certain goals man and
um man you you giving a breakdown like
yo you on point like a scoreboard like
you definitely that's what I do man
that's what I do there's no [__]
straight shooter I like that we need we
need that yeah I mean because you know
dudes you
they're like
they had to keep it real because you
know it's all for the sake of having
that opportunity to slide up in them
draws man yeah I mean but you you not
with it you you straight shooting you
like you let it know what it is what it
is and I mean and I I I a guy like me
appreciate
truth and wisdom like that because it
definitely you should Implement and
that's into your lifestyle and and not
to fall into the snares of this game man
because you know like each move you make
when you're dealing with these females
man it's you if you're not on point
y'all man you're gonna be taking it out
all across the board I mean it's it's
very risky to get involved with the
women today on an intimate basis when
you when you form a relationship
especially in North America especially
in any Western Country where laws are
hostile towards men and especially
fathers so you have to be very very
careful you have to be very selective
um you know like the main dating
strategy that guys should be using
should be really dating multiple women
simultaneously in a non-monogamous
fashion if your goal is just to have fun
then that's really all that you ever
need to do now if your goal changes and
you're and you're thinking yourself all
right you know I'm tired of the
nightmares I'm tired of all this
[__] I'm you know tired of this
taking up all my time and they start on
down the route of maybe I'd like a
girlfriend or maybe they want to go
further than that and say you know maybe
I want to have a family sort of thing
and start having some kids that's when
you know you can take a look at your
dating pool and then say to yourself you
know look I've been dating these women
for so long some of them have been
asking me questions like where do we
stand you know are you seeing anybody
else are we going to be exclusive sort
of thing that's when you can start
entertaining those conversations and
even then if you do entertain them you
don't have to be monogamous you know you
can set up your life in such a way that
if you want be monogamous with her right
if you you know if you so choose or if
you don't want that and you want to have
options and set up your life and say all
right I choose you but just understand
I'm going to step outside from time to
time but don't worry it's not going to
take away anything from you I'm not
going to hurt you I'm not going to
embarrass you I'm not going to bring
home a disease there's all kinds of ways
that you can structure your life but
guys don't realize that there's more
than one way to skin a cat right there's
a whole bunch of different ways you can
live your life as a guy depending on how
you want to structure and what your
goals are I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're newer to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out